hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to factorial now this game
came out recently and it's actually very
very confusing I'll show you why
ahh what is all of this what am i doing
what the hell okay so this game is one
that says it's infinitely scalable which
literally means the map that you're in
this this area that we're in here does
not end and there is no limit to the
amount of resources that you can get
which I have to do by slamming what I
hope is a hammer and not any part of me
into these rocks until I get the
materials that I need and when I do that
I will be able to build things
constantly and forever expanding until
it covers the entire world and you can
see the world map in factories now I
don't know how to play this game so what
you're gonna see now is a montage of me
losing my goddamn mind trying to figure
this [ __ ] out you got it okay let's go
cuz we got one one iron from all of that
I was killing time okay fine this is
going to be a [ __ ] but we're gonna get
there cuz I can get a furnace
I got a stone furnace I'm gonna go from
the Stone Age and the objective is to go
to the moon this is a cow oh it's a
mining drill that would be so much
easier than me hitting whit with my dick
oh it's not a fuel how do I get fuel I
can craft logistics production oh god oh
god oh I don't know oh I don't know I'll
get a pickaxe cool did I yay oh god oh
that's much easier I was hitting it with
my dick that's so much better
also I have a gun so I'm assuming that
I'm gonna get attacked in any moment
it's gonna be bad everyone wants a piece
of the marquee mooo everyone wants some
my factories now I bet there's some guys
out there watching this or gals I'm not
excluding that know how to play this
game and yes I'm going to be very
but by the time we get to the end of
this very short episode I'm gonna be
good at it so you'll see yeah oh I can
put wood I can put wood and then yeah
that's how you do it okay that's good I
want to get more iron blade out of it
yes I know how to play the game I'm not
that bad I'm pretty bad okay so if I
take some of the fuel back I take these
iron plates out I put this fuel in whoa
oh that's not what I wanted
BAM ah oh ah thank you
oh you're delightful oh cool ah okay
we're getting it we're getting there
okay stone I need stone where's stone me
am need rock me I'm need Rocky is this
rock is this me I'm Rock what is all
that is that a more iron Oh
hug hug me em get Rock to make steam
engine and then get more mining grill
for me technology unga-bunga
you gonna get there eventually with time
age of empire style goddamn it I'm back
to hitting it with my dick okay so I can
make three stone furnace I I can put no
wait no I can use these to then make
iron gear how do I make an iron gear oh
that's how I make an iron you ah ah this
is what I meant by infinite scalability
because things start to go up real quick
is this coal or some it is Cole I need
coal
okay coal is gonna be good because coal
is a better fuel than whatever the hell
I was using before so this is gonna be
good okay we're gonna get there
eventually
the thing about infinite scalability is
that it starts out slow so stop judging
me is really cool by the way
I will admit it's kind of an interesting
concept just like a vicious cycle that
feeds itself and glitz legally in the
time okay now they're going what does
that mean oh oh they're full oh okay so
I need to I need to find a way to go
I need more mom okay so I got to get a
conveyer system putting
over here but to do that I need more
stuff ah ah there we go
okay oh and then we dump these into oh
that ain't working okay so what I
figured out thus far but I haven't been
able to piece it together exactly is I
figured out how to make conveyer belts
and take the resources in to some other
place but I haven't figured out how to
dump it into the furnace which is my
next goal I will get this done though
will ah burner inserter burner insert a
burner burner burner burner inserter
earner insert our ah yes burner insert
or uh ah we have found something so
there is no fuel in either of these I
need more fuel this needs fuel I got
fuel for it boink fuel for that that's
good and then put fuel in here and we
are in business
yes does it yes that works oh my god it
works it works oh my god it works holy
crap it works I know this is tiny but
this is a monumental thing for me this
works holy crap it works that's so cool
oh that's so cool that may not seem cool
to you guys but this is so cool because
this opens up so much more potential
there's so many things that I could do
with this this is insanity it's so cool
okay so if I do this oh no it not that
okay so I need oh no I don't need to oh
I don't even need to do that I can just
do this and flip it the other way and
just like that and then put fuel in
these bad boys put you in there put you
in there and we're in business
holy crap we're in business that's good
what the hell so cool oh so cool and
then I can get in Surtur's for getting
coal and putting coal in the coal
machines and then oh wow I could put
coal in the coal machine in the mining
machines and then the mining machines
deliver coal to every other thing oh my
god this takes so much planning god I
need more time
this is so cool though oh cool
a boiler ahh a boiler what would a
boiler before steam engine okay power
output oh so I could make electricity eh
alright here's the deal I'm starting to
learn the game I'm not quite at expert
level yet I don't have all the resources
that I need I need a lot more fuel fuel
is the one thing that I need so to power
all this I need to figure out a better
way to get power than just putting
things in but until that time comes I
have these things cranking out like a
boss that should be turned the other way
there we go I have these things cranking
out like a boss getting me all the stone
and coal that I'm gonna need for the
future and this is gonna keep going this
is just gonna keep doing this now I
think I could have these dumping into
chests I believe I'm pretty sure I could
just have these nope that's not how that
works apparently okay maybe I need an
inserter to put it in the chest now it
makes sense there we go yeah okay there
we go and it's putting it in the chest
nice but it needs more fuel God
everything needs fuel whoops oh crap
crap crap crap
everything's gone bad get more coal for
it fill this up a fuel cos gonna run out
Oh since it's grabbing coal as it did it
just get cold for itself it did it got
coal for itself because it's grabbing
coal this is a very exciting time for me
oh so exciting okay but I've got stone
and I've got coal and I kind of forgot
about these bad boys which probably ran
out of fuel a long time ago so I've got
an infinite source of fuel and then
hopefully I've got a damn decent source
of everything else No
I don't yeah yeah down a fuel a ride
coal production has increased cost on
production has stopped but it's doing
it's doing it its turn the thing it's
doing the thing it's doing the thing
yeah yeah
okay so there's another resource over
here copper okay so coppers gotta be
used for a whole bunch of other stuff
I'm just gonna dig some up by hand at
first and then I'm gonna get a I'm gonna
get a mining drill over here cuz mining
and automation is all what this game is
about copper play ah okay so I need to
smelt the copper and to do that I think
there was a larger copper deposit over
here yeah over here
I don't know this is too far and I
believe it's oh that's oil ooh
wonder what I could do with oil can't
even mine man okay so I was doing a
little bit of preparing in the
background while I was assembling
materials what I have is I have copper
going into a smelter and I'm getting
copper plate from that which I'm gonna
need for electronics
I've got coal being shunted into this
thing at regular intervals and I'm gonna
make more of that soon and I'm saving up
and I'm stockpiling materials so that
down the road I'll be able to just blast
out as much as possible which is gonna
be very important because the next step
everything is very disparate right now
everything is very far away from each
other what I'm gonna do in the next one
is I'm going to make sure that
everything flows into each other and
figure out how to do that best because
I'm not entirely sure how I can get
everything the fuel going into the right
places and the not fuel going into the
right places I'm not sure I can do that
just yet but I do know that when this
thing grabs coal it will always grab
enough coal for itself and that's
handy-dandy information so I just need
to get more more more capitalism I mean
factories going sorry okay so now that I
have copper I can actually make some of
the cooler things that I do need like
these science packs these electronic
circuits I can make the offshore pump
the electric mining drill which sounds
pretty cool and actually consumes a lot
less energy than the other one it has
more health and has a bigger mining area
yeah
I'll way bigger mining area and a faster
speed that sounds cool I want that how
do I get that I want a lot of that ooh
can I get that and then I can make a lab
which I'm assuming is something that I
actually need so I'm gonna Wow okay so
whenever I click on something bigger
like a lab it makes all the other
material first and then it does that so
I was not actually able to do any of
this I clicked on this but I don't even
think it did anything because I did not
have a lab yet so once this is done and
I do have a lab we're probably gonna see
something interesting happening but
probably not because I have no idea what
I'm doing still but this is so cool this
is just really cool it's just a giant
world that you can build it builds
itself it's nuts all right what do you
got oh it needs actual power automation
I need that modules science packs so I
need all this stuff and then the next
thing that I'm gonna need is I'm
actually gonna need power so I'm going
to need a boiler and a steam engine so
I'm gonna build a boiler and a steam
engine I'm gonna build an offshore pump
I don't even know what that's gonna do
I'm gonna build a bunch of pipe I don't
know how to do this yet pipe the ground
sure sound good to me
I don't know I don't know okay all right
anyway put some fuel in it for some
reason getting offshore oh oh I can zoom
out oh my god I did not know that I can
do that
holy crap it makes the world seem a lot
smaller okay but we're gonna stay nice
and tight right here God that just
changed everything okay so now we need
to put the steam engine whoa that's
bigger than I thought it'd be okay so
that's there um where'd my pipes go I
know I built pipes
okay offshore pump okay so we're gonna
pump this hopefully okay so that's water
okay so that's definitely going in there
you got to put the boiler like right ah
aha okay but the boiler there put the
fuel in there it's gonna boil up and
then steam will go into here a question
mark there yeah okay
all right is that doing it correctly I
oh it's got water it doesn't have enough
steam no it's got steam ah what am I
missing I'm missing something the
temperature is very low Oh Oh I just
need to connect the two of them okay so
that's now working yes and this is now
powered oh my god oh my god I'm actually
doing science now I'm gonna make these
science packs I don't know what they're
gonna do but I'm gonna shove them in oh
it's not done yet okay I was wondering
so I'm gonna shove these into here and
they're going to do something okay I
heard a sound that's like the 400 what
all right we got all the materials that
we need and we get the science lab going
which means that it's studying
automation but it's not quite there yet
I need more of these and I've got more
of these because I accidentally produced
all of them but it's gonna do that and I
don't know what the modules do but I
imagine that they probably make it go
faster and then this works towards
automation which is working currently
and then I'll get more things that I can
make but I'm actually all out of time
for this episode I've been playing this
game a long time this is really really
ridiculously cool I want to pick this
game up again so I'm gonna do another
episode of it I'm actually might do a
few more episodes of it just because
it's really cool dick I mean this is
really really cool so I'm gonna give
this go but thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
of this game in the comments below I
really want to hear you guys's opinion
on this because this is nuts
this is bonkers it's so cool and you can
find the game it's on Steam I forget how
much it cost but there's a link in the
description so thank you again everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[ __ ]